all the machines in this arcade homemade
there's something magical about all this
as a child I found that making things
that made people laugh was satisfying
and seemed more point in doing that than
making useful machines
[Music]
I'm Tim Duncan and I'm a cartoonist and
engineer I have two arcades
one on the coast and appear and this one
in central London called novelty
automation in total I suppose I've made
about 50 machines not many people have
that as their ambition in life but yeah
it suits me
this is petal meet you spin the wheel
and you find if the land ends up sitting
with you on the sofa or being carved for
dinner it was a hobby that got out of
control
this is Auto frisk you stand in front
here the gloves inflate and then they
act you down Britain's got a great
history of satire and I suppose I'm not
really particularly political myself but
I think it's healthy for little people
to poke fun at the rich and powerful you
fly this little drone round this Beverly
Hills mansion and see all the stars
inside and your paparazzi you have to
try and take the photos to fill up the
cover of the magazine I get my ideas
from lots of places it's partly things
happening in my life partly things
happening in the news and partly from
old arcade machines and mechanisms this
is test your nerve you have to put your
hand inside the cage with the mad dog
for as long as you dare
to do something like this you have to
enjoy the process of making things I
spent most of my life solving
conventional engineering problems rather
than thinking up the jokes this is the
chiropodist you have to take off your
shoe for this one you put your foot in
the treatment bay down the bottom and it
feels really weird seeing people
enjoying using the machines keeps me at
it
and also because they take money it
provides the income to let me keep at it
so to me it's a pretty perfect system it
sure beats working I never planned my
career or anything about my life it's
just occasionally a sort of opportunity
comes up and then I go through
[Music]